while canyoneering is a brand-new sport
it starts with an old-school leap of
faith its participants hold their breath
as they repel down seemingly bottomless
canyons formed by centuries of wind and
water through oncoming waterfalls around
blind turns and dangling over cliffs the
sports pioneers take on natural wonders
the rest of us would never dare KITT
Turner is one of those pioneers he and
his team are about to enter Canada's box
canyon for the first time a place that
will make their knees quake
I got started running canyons in Hawaii
I started rock climbing and eventually
made the progression into Canyon area
then as my girlfriend she's a Hawaii
girl born and raised we've been dating
now for almost two years
we met climbing kit always pushes me to
go it's on me comfort level a lot you're
talking about canyoneering the process
of descending a canyon you have to
decide how much rope you want to bring
along you want to decide if the rock
quality is gonna be good enough to set
up anchors for the rappels
you also have to find a good crew that
is good under pressure you're just
dealing with lots of complexities of
nature rocks waterfall
it's just constant problem solving using
your brain using your body onions are
very fickle and they're very weather
dependent conditions in a canyon can
change from one day to the next from one
season to the next
for this particular Canyon box canyon
you have to cross the Squamish river
kayaking across the river it was an
ordeal because you just really have to
paddle your heart out just to cut across
that current and then you have to make a
sharp you turn into this little tiny
beach front so once you cross the river
there's a mosquito-infested hike into
kind of the bottom of the box canyon
stream and then you hike upstream for a
while before you get to the technical
part of the canyon which involves rope
the first thought was is this man-made
this is not real
it looks like a Disneyland ride
box canyon is considered a Class C
Canyon
most of the repels if not all the repels
you're going straight through the
watercourse which is straight through
the waterfall and you're you're getting
pounded by the water tinning in your
face you're slipping you're sliding all
over the place my favorite thing about
dropping into a canyon is the rush of
getting over the edge this is my passion
man I gotta get more pumpkin when I'm in
a canyon it kind of adds that element of
excitement where you can't see where
you're gonna end up
when you're on the edge as an adventurer
when you feel like I could die doing
this right now but I can't back down and
then you do it it's like the most
amazing feeling I don't get the people
that are like why would you do that I'm
just like why not if you don't get it
you don't get it for someone who's
looking everything what we did which is
dropping everything and pursuing your
dreams I would say that it's definitely
a leap of faith and maybe you crash and
burn but the highs are incredible and
you're never gonna get those amazing
moments and see if you can really
achieve your dreams if you don't try
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]